c'est l'un des weekends les plus achat
landés de l'année parce qu'il y a encore
des clients qui n'ont pas tous leurs
cadeau de Noël parce que même si la
concurrence du commerce en ligne est
rude lécher les vitrines et faire les
boutiques ça a encore du charme ça y est
c'est quasiment fini voilà les derniers
cadeaux sont bouclés puis là c'est le
plaisir de de faire les boutiques pour
Noël c'est toujours agréable le charme
aussi de ces boutiques spécialisés dans
les jeux en tout genre beaux objets jeux
de société à offrir ou à s'offrir pour
occuper un soir de réveillon cette année
les jeux d'enquête et les jeux d'énigmes
comme les unlock et cetera fonctionnent
fonctionnent beaucoup euh
particulièrement parce qu'on peut y
jouer soit à deux ou soit à 4 5 6 enfin
voilà et c'est assez facile à prendre en
main et pour les commerçants des grandes
enseignes c'est de toute évidence Noël
avant l'heure la plus grosse période
d'achat de toute une année c'est comme
on dit le le moneytime en terme
d'activité et de résultat le mois de
décembre pour le grand magasin c'est à
peu pr 15 % de l'activité de l'année
donc c'est très important ensuite il y
aura une sorte de ciel de train des
achats entre les fêtes pour dépenser le
contenu des enveloppes puis viendra le
temps des soldes et peut-être l'occasion
de prendre de l'avance à moindre coût
sur les cadeaux de Noël l'année
prochaine car tout comme gouverner faire
plaisir c'est
prévoir